Over the last couple of years, RAM and
storage have become unreasonably
expensive. And while there are some
signs that the RAM apocalypse may ease
in the near to mid [music] future, SSDs
and even the humble hard drive are
showing no signs of coming back down to
Earth, which really sucks because the
amount of data that we need to back up
is only increasing. So, what do we do,
Marty? We need to go back to the past to
find the future of storage. Could
Blu-rays be the solution to this crisis?
It's not as crazy as it sounds,
especially when you look at the first
thing on everyone's minds, cost. We
compared the cheapest consumer options
across a variety of mediums and
capacities and found that blank Blu-rays
were by far the cheapest option
available by a factor of nearly two and
3x over hard drives and SSDs,
respectively. In fact, the only medium
that can touch optical in value is
linear tape open format, which has a
very big problem, and that is the
extremely high startup cost, especially
for the newer ones. That means you need
to invest a lot more into that medium
before you hit the break even versus
Blu-ray. Now, there are some obvious
downsides to burnable media, which we
will touch on later, but the basic point
stands. If you are archiving files under
the right circumstances, you can save
big money by going optical.
>> Just like I saved big money on this
segue to our sponsor,
>> Meter. They provide enterprise full
stack networking infrastructure and
they'll even help you migrate from your
current setup. Check the link down below
or stay tuned to the end of this video
to find out more. Before we go any
further, it's important to clarify that
not all types of data are appropriate
for Blu-ray backup. For instance,
anything that I want to access with a
reasonable frequency or at high speed
would be considered hot data and is best
kept on my local system drive or on a
NAS where it can be [music] instantly
recalled. Cold data, by contrast, is
made up of files that aren't regularly
being accessed. And examples of this
would be things like archived business
records that nobody really needs to look
at unless you get audited or large raw
versions of family photos if you happen
to be a passionate shutterbug. This is
the type of thing that is not only a
perfect candidate for Blu-ray, but maybe
even better to store on discs. Let me
explain. Every electronic device has an
expected [music] lifespan. Just like
with humans, taking proper care of those
electronics can help to extend that
lifespan. But eventually they're all
going to die or lose their data. Hard
drives, for instance, actually track
their power on hours as a way of
estimating how much life they have left.
Okay, well, no problem. Why don't you
just leave them powered off then, right?
Ah, not so fast. While there are drives
that are more designed around archival
powered off applications, even those do
contain sensitive moving parts that can
eventually degrade. As for SSDs, they
might be a little more comfortable at
rest. You could store them on a shelf
for years or even decades before they
would just [snorts] die. But if you were
to do so, I hope you weren't planning to
pull any data off [music] of them.
Because anytime an SSD isn't powered on,
the electrons slowly leak through the
insulating layer in the storage cells,
which eventually causes bit flips, which
leads to silent file corruption. Also,
SSDs would just be crazy expensive for
archival storage. By contrast, Blu-ray
discs are designed to be temporarily
used and then tucked into a sleeve or a
jewel case for a long sleep. With that
being said, though, not all Blu-rays are
equal in this regard. Regular Blu-ray
discs are rated for anywhere between 5
to 50 years, depending on their quality
and their materials, which is um a
pretty huge window. And it gets even
bigger if we include misc Blu-rays, a
type that uses even more expensive
materials to make them theoretically
last for over a 100red years. Now, of
course, these more expensive materials
lead to more expensive discs and
slightly less compatibility across our
drives, which does kind of throw a
wrench into our earlier value numbers.
But being confident that your data will
outlast your mortal body is probably
worth the price for the right people.
Another big advantage for Blu-ray is
it's kind of perfect if you have a
projectbased workflow. Many professional
photographers and videographers archive
their work. And physical discs are a
easy and cheap to label in store, b a
lot simpler to ship to an old client or
to a partner, and c a lot more secure
than anything on the cloud. On that
subject, if you're someone with
sensitive files that you don't want
online, Blu-rays are perfect for locking
them away safely in the safety of a
safe. And if you add per disk encryption
on top of that, it is going to be very
hard for bad actors to get their hands
on your data without literally breaking
into your house and coercing you into
going and getting your Blu-rays and
opening the files FOR THEM. SO, WOW,
BLU-RAYS are amazing. I should take this
hard drive shirt off of ltdtstore.com
right now and replace it with our
awesome new percussive maintenance
technician design.
>> Oh, slow down there, Tiger. I think it's
time to tell people the all the reasons
they probably shouldn't go blue. Da d d
d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d da d
da.
>> Yeah. Okay, first up is the extra time
and planning that it takes to get your
data burned. If all you have to back up
is 50 to 100 gigs, you can do that on a
single disc. But if you have even a
modestsized hard drive worth of data,
let's say 20 terabytes, that's going to
take you 450
gig Blu-ray discs, each of which will
take anywhere from 35 to 50 minutes to
burn at 4x speed. Even if you manage to
get the time in between discs [music]
where you organize the files, swap your
discs, and get the next burn going down
to, let's say, 2 minutes, you are still
looking at a cool 13 hours of just the
actual hands-on time, and that's on top
of the more than 230 hours of burning
time.
Compare that to the 70ish hours of
mostly handsoff time that it would take
to do that on hard drives, even at a
very pedestrian 80 megabytes a second.
And that is a big difference. Making
matters even worse, you rarely need the
exact capacity of a Blu-ray, meaning
that you will almost certainly end up
leaving some space blank on every single
disc. That can quickly add up, pushing
the price per gig way up. Now, you could
fill that space with smaller files just
to avoid wasting it, but then keeping
track of where those files are becomes
an absolute nightmare. Then there's the
physical space. Even though an
individual Blu-ray is, I mean, pretty
small, right? If you're doing any kind
of serious archiving, they start to add
up. Based on some quick napkin math, if
you were to fill a milk crate with
Blu-rays that are protected only by
paper sleeves, you could get anywhere
from 880 to a,000 discs. That's about 44
to 100 terabytes, depending on the
capacity of the discs, which is a lot.
The only problem is it's a lot less than
the 350 tab that you could fit in that
same milk crate if you were using 14 TB
hard drives. Not to mention that those
hard drives would be much more versatile
and that you could quickly and reliably
rewrite, reuse, or even resell them.
Something that you uh can't really do
with write once media. Now, there are
rewritable Blu-rays. It's just that they
are much more expensive and slower to
burn, which once again throws our
earlier favorable calculation into the
dumpster. There are things you could do
to optimize the Blu-ray workflow, like
using a multi-burner. But hard drives
are just so much more usable. And as
soon as you get into the really large
archiving projects, the value of tape is
[music] impossible to ignore. And that's
a trend that doesn't seem likely to
change. With tape getting ever more
advanced and Blu-ray prices continuing
to go up as companies slowly exit the
market. So, uh, nice bait and switch,
Lionus. Blu-ray is great. Wait, no, it
actually totally sucks. What exactly is
the takeaway here? Well, it's that for
some people, Blu-ray could make a lot of
sense and might not have been the sort
of thing that they would think about.
Sure, it's not great for everyone, but
any options out there for preserving our
precious data in these trying times are
at least worth considering and being
educated on. Now, if you'll excuse me,
I'm just going to pop in this segue to
our sponsor, Meter. Sometimes a
networking team just isn't big enough to
juggle the amount of tasks that are
expected of them. When vendors are
asking more and more of them, you start
to see the side effects and not just the
monetary ones. Meter helps solve this by
delivering full stack networking
infrastructure across internet, wired,
wireless, and cellular. Unlike legacy
networking, which isn't built to meet
modern demands, and often isn't
scalable, meter very much is. They even
design, deploy, and manage the networks
for you. This is all with the assurance
that there is no high-risk ripandrel
headache. You'll get migration credits,
24/7 support, and predictable
subscription pricing. Meter also offers
constellation of networking components
into one vertically integrated solution
for things like warehouses, campuses, or
data centers. Thanks to Meter for
sponsoring this video. Go to
meter.com/ltt
and book that demo now. That's
me.com/ltt
to book a demo. If you guys enjoyed this
video, why not check out the time that
we did a detailed breakdown of the cost
difference between discs versus digital.
[music] The answer may surprise